When you do it with that wacky fade,
the one face that you picked for the face swaps,
so perfect because it looks like he's out of control.
Then they say he's like crazy.
Jesus.
What's happening again?
Fucking amazing man for years up.
It's amazing.
Did you see that?
What's going on today?
Tom Arnold who hates Trump has a new show on vice or he's just running around
trying to find incriminating video and audio w on Trump.
Ooh,
that's all he's done.
The whole show is him on a quest to find incriminating and humiliating video and
audio on Trump and he was with Michael Cohen today.
What?
Yes.
How could he,
Michael Cohen is apparently going to work with Tom Arnold on the show.
Who is he?
Is the FBI okay with that and I think they'd be like,
yeah,
they were together.
This photo,
I mean Tom Arnold could be just bullshitting.
Well,
I'm tabling that.
Tivo,
Tivo and does anymore.
Why don't you just get off the VCR?
Do you know how to work the client now?
I had things come out of my mouth where it shows my age.
What is this Jamie Twitter.
This is on Tom Arnold.
Did the Miss Universe tape.
There's another tape
talking about 16 year old girls in their underwear here.
Okay,
let's go celebrity apprentice Trump denies any involvement with,
don't worry Tom Arnold is on it and I'm Tom Arnold
for the Trump tapes with Tom Arnold.
I mean,
no one's going to care no matter what.
What he uh,
it's not going to have an effect probably,
but yeah.
Listen,
Fuck John Gotti.
Trump is a Teflon.
Don,
you see that movie?
They're saying they scam rotten tomatoes.
Would that move post to be the greatest movie of all time?
We'll get to zero and then Haiti from the audience and like 90%.
Where was from their employees thinking that correction on the Michael.
How,
when was that taken correction?
Some sort of correction?
It did.
He didn't say me and him were teaming up to take down Donald Trump.
Michael has enough Trump on his plate.
I'm the crazy person who said me and Michael Cohen,
we're teaming up to take down Trump.
Of course.
I meant it.
Michael doesn't get paid by vice.
Okay.
Thank you Tom for correcting the record.
Okay,
thanks.
Thanks for clearing that up.
Damn.
That's what I feel like he was Tom Arnold.
I'd be nervous as fuck.
Why?
I don't want to get killed.
Oh,
now impossible.
Impossible.
You can't kill Tom Arnold would if Putin did it for a favor,
Putin might be able to do it.
Put some voices,
decides.
I don't like what you're doing with the Lakewood,
the IV.
None.
This is not that good.
The Russian accent.
Would you consider doing a Putin on your page?
Ooh,
I will.
Yes.
That's a good idea.
It's a great idea.
What?
These little lotion that is.
He's the Russian accent because he's good.
There's some bad just to listen to him talk a few times and you'd,
you'd get it.
I'm potent.
That's good.
And then how a bunch of like really harsh Russian prostitutes like water flying
all over the place.
Like [inaudible].
Yeah,
I see it next week.
I mean that's not a bad idea for a sketch.
Is there a pee tape or is that a,
is that a rumor or do we not know this?
I don't know.
I don't think it's supposed to be real.
I think it's supposed to be fake.
I it sounds fake.
It sounds like something someone would just make up like not even well planned
out.